[Music]
who's there
[Music]
okay
you need breakfast i'm fine i wasn't
asking nolan wright
involved in a car accident resulting in
the death of his wife
is there anyone else who can pick you up
it's just running a little late today
and severe memory loss
if this happens again we're gonna have
to notify child services
i believe that i can reverse your
condition we should give it a shot right
come with me please
we call this headset the black box
an immersive virtual pathway to your
memories i like to begin with something
i call
a safe room when you push the crown of
the watch you will be in your
subconscious
are you ready
what rachel hell's in there it's your
brain trying to protect you from your
trauma
did you go well with dr brooks today i
saw my wedding
that's progress right there if that
thing
shows up again you just say to yourself
i run my mind it does not run me
i'm in my mind it doesn't hurt me i run
my mind
it doesn't run me
patients are often surprised by what
they remember
did rachel and i live in an apartment i
don't think so the place was really
familiar
you're getting close stay with this did
we ever fight
it's not what you think you would never
hurt rachel
what's going on we're close i can sense
it
you just need to remember who you are i
run my mind
it doesn't run me
[Music]
[Music]
you